hey everybody and welcome to a redeeming
wild ride with stevo this week we have
controversial rapper lil xan who's very
open and candid about his drug addiction
about
frankly a lot of mistakes that he's made
and uh he got me really rooting for him
and that's why i really see this as
redemption for the kid very juicy
podcast as well and speaking of juicy
have i told you about liquid death this
canned water company which is basically
saving the world because they're trying
to bring death to plastic
plastic as i'm sure you know is killing
the world meanwhile the infinitely
recyclable aluminum cans liquid death
uses are saving the world and gosh is it
exciting they've got these new flavored
waters now mango chainsaw severed lime
and bury it alive
the stuff's so delicious i can't even
keep it in the house you know it's true
and the company is doing so well it's
now in target albertson 7-11 whole foods
i mean it's just popping up everywhere
and i love it because everybody is just
getting on the team to save the world
now you can get this without even
leaving your house and not pay a dime
for shipping because if you go to
liquiddeth.com
stevo it's free shipping for all of your
orders of water and merch very generous
of liquid death a great company that's
saving the world so one more time go to
liquiddeth.com for this insanely
generous deal and now let's get into it
is that okay uh to have a red bull of
course
you know
this is like a good uh
yeah i mean it's wherever you feel
comfortable oh yeah i've done podcasts
before like all in
ah yeah thank you man for having me on
dude thank you man this killer that you
reached out but
i i'm still not sure if you were just
responding to us having reached out to
you
uh well wait have you did you guys reach
out first why i saw the clip i watched
the clip oh but there was over with the
island voice yeah yeah right yeah
and then i was like well i'll shoot my
shot because like uh i did tim dillon's
podcast first okay and then i did a
couple of no jumpers and uh i'm doing
impulsive in like a week with like logan
paul
so yeah i'm trying to just you know cool
and this is cool as [ __ ] too because i
grew up watching
jackass you know like all right
i feel like we have a lot of
similarities too because i'm just coming
out of like my you know real bad drug
phase like i was really [ __ ] bad too
all right let's keep you on the mic
and uh we're rolling in everything yes
sir all right here it is
ladies and gentlemen
lil xan hey what's going on guys
how are you i'm doing man thank you for
having me thanks for being here
san diego san diego like san diego right
you know funny story about that my
parents actually wanted to name me sam
diego that's funny and i was like please
don't do that to me
yeah yeah but yeah thank you guys again
for having me man for sure man it was up
it was pretty rad you reached out
on instagram because of course i follow
you yeah and i came right into my dm box
and i was like no way man
uh because we had just reached out to
you
to get you on the podcast i didn't see i
didn't even see that that's crazy we
reached out to each other about making
this happen it was meant to be yeah as
it was meant to be because i didn't even
see the first one but i saw that the
clip on thing and i was like well i'll
shoot my shot you know i love the
podcast i watch it yeah i saw the island
boys podcast yeah i remember one of the
island boys said that uh that he speaks
with you the
relationship with him is that true yeah
that is true but i i also heard i don't
know if this is true because i don't
watch uh like some like island boy
podcast and like when they're just not
my favorite but um we used to have a
friendship but they just kept calling me
every day like three times a day and i
think they got butt hurt because i just
refused to keep answering you know
because they would ask dumb questions
not talking [ __ ] i'm just saying they
would ask
like they were excited yeah
yeah i'm excited yeah they they're cool
people but they would just be like oh
how much money you make you have more
money i don't know i just don't want to
talk about this i know where that
and i think that's where they got butt
hurt and started talking a little [ __ ]
on the internet about me because i
stopped responding to it right but i
have nothing against the island boy but
and he was talking on the show about he
was talking to you like when you were in
the hospital right was that accurate i
didn't i haven't seen anything actually
i i i've been trying to stay off the
yeah the interweb okay um i thought that
those guys were legitimately talented
when they just started freestyling on
our podcast did you see that no i did
not see that one did they just
buzz i mean i'm sure it was kind of
prepared
i don't know it wasn't every uh
freestyle was a little pre-written yeah
but you can tell when it's like wow this
is just a yes
freestyle and it wasn't like that yeah
it was a little sloppy it was like a
little like it was real you know yeah
yeah it was cool yeah i have nothing
against them i like them i like i
there's a lot of similarities between me
and them you know we look crazy it's
just different timing um yeah oh yeah
that's crazy okay so i gotta just come
right out of the gate and say i've been
confused
by a couple things because uh
like we spoke on the phone the other day
yes like right after you reached out and
uh i told you that i had seen you on tmz
yeah and that the story was you just got
out of rehab and that you're sober
mm-hmm and uh 40 days yeah and then 30
days
that's great
the story was also that the rehab you
went to somehow encourages
smoking marijuana yeah well about that
well i went to a detox center first
called vita nova shout out to them um
they don't allow weed at that they just
do the normal uh scheduled things they
do that's in newport beach i was uh they
gave me a scholarship actually so i
don't have to pay
um so i'm very grateful for the people
that vita nova
and i detox for 30 days there got
cleaned so i wasn't withdrawing when i
went to
the other place the place you're
referring to the heavenly center which
is uh steve labelle scott storch the
producer gotcha um and a couple other
people that run it and the heavenly
center aka you know abbreviated thc you
know they don't force you to smoke weed
uh you know they don't like like you
know like say you have to smoke weed to
like get better they just say if it
helps it helps and i'm not a big weed
smoker myself
um that's what confuses me
but more because we saw we went back and
looked at that actual tmz clip
where uh they they i guess you were on
hollywood boulevard or something i was
at bullets bullet steakhouse boys yeah
and you said in that clip to tmz you're
like i'm a big pot guy
i don't know yeah okay okay okay i'm
gonna come clean i smoke a blood like
maybe every like i'll smoke two blunts a
week but i was maybe i was just i was
trying to like i mean whatever i'm not
mad at you i'm just like i was kind of i
was kind of trying to shout out the
heavenly center more because they
reposted it so i wanted them to think
that yeah like it helped me out a lot
but then just yesterday
like you like you posted this thing with
like like i i ate edibles and i got so
suited and loaded oh no no no that that
scripted that was scripted i just did a
collaboration with uh my good friends uh
that that make edibles and weed called
gassy and uh and that was more of like
and we did a scripted thing i i don't i
don't eat edibles i'll end up at the
hospital on edibles you know what i mean
and uh we just did a a
collaboration for uh keith world joints
and delta eight gummies so they paid me
to make that whole skit where i'm going
in to in and out and perfectly
entertaining i'm sure yeah but i didn't
eat i didn't eat any of that but uh i
did i do i did smoke a couple of the
joints but it's not like my main thing
like yeah i mean
can i ask you yeah what was your main
thing when you said you were like a
detoxing like what were you
when i went to vita nova i was coming
off of probably taking uh
20 nothing there was no fentanyl in my
system by the way uh
is that a rumor that's going around they
had fun no no no i'm just saying that
there wasn't because usually people get
fake [ __ ] you know what i mean
everything's fake does anybody take
fentanyl on purpose yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it seems like it's all these
like fake pills where they're they cut
with fennel they're the
little blue uh
perk 30s are like the most commonly
faked ones why i had a guy yesterday
that was he was in rehab he's like i
just went in there and he's like
everything's cut with it anyway so i
might as well just do fentanyl he's like
if that makes sense i'm like that
doesn't make any sense at all the
problem with these fake pills is like at
first people didn't like them because
they wanted what they wanted you know
what i mean but now they like they like
say like they like xanax so when they
were getting fake xanax they didn't like
it but now
that the xanax has fentanyl in it
they're they they like the fentanyl and
they're getting addicted to a whole
nother substance opiates how common is
it to have fentanyl in something that
people it is probably uh
the things being sold in la right now i
would say 95 percent of everything is uh
every drug is cut with uh fentanyl
something like the fake pill where they
press it yeah but it's cocaine it's it's
everything
that's what killed my friend mac miller
it was uh fentanyl ace cocaine can you
help us understand why
on
[ __ ]
is it like
like
cocaine and fentanyl
it's like it's like it's what they used
to cut it you know what i mean like how
they like baby lacks a different power
now they're doing fentanyl to make it
stronger it makes it it makes your
product a little stronger but what the
problem is is this is like you know with
the labs wherever they [ __ ] make it
someone adds
two pounds more of the wrong batch and
then you got a deadly batch that's going
to hit the streets you know what i mean
like they they they miscalculate because
they're in jungles they're not in the
laboratories
like whoops [ __ ] yeah whoops i put a
teaspoon in now
i wonder if they're trying to make
people addicted to fentanyl they are you
know like get them off the coke and
slowly introduce fentanyl and then all
you're selling because fun fact fentanyl
back like 20 years ago was like a very
niche drug it was only used as like
anesthesia and pain medicine it's like
open heart surgery yeah people out for
longer
on a patch and they would put them yeah
it was the pain people would like chew
the patch instead of having yes that
taxi out started but like like if you
would have went into a hospital 20 years
ago or no not a hospital a rehab and
said they would have been like what are
you addicted to and said fentanyl they
would have been like
what is that where did you get that like
you know what i mean yeah but
you didn't finish what you're saying
what would you go in for your 20
milligrams i was taking about 20
vicodins or what they call them
hydrocodones uh now and uh about 10 10
xanax today but everything was real
because i was paying out of pocket for
like old people on hospice's scripts and
you know because i i don't like fentanyl
i've never been addicted to fentanyl
myself what's old people on hospice like
you know like like uh like you're
getting prescribed legit stuff at a
legit business versus like scoring on
the street because they have like one or
two years left to live and
they want to make extra money so they
sell it and stuff
what's the detox like uh from xanax is
it like vertigo i heard it's kind of
like your vision flip it's like
let's face it if you got a detox that
might mean that your lifestyle is less
than healthy but let me tell you what is
totally healthy because i am in love
with it athletic greens this is a
natural supplement that is absolutely
delicious and fills in all of the gaps
in my diet which sadly i have
some of uh now every serving is
convenient comprehensive and literally
gives me all of the nutrition i need for
a whole day
it's got 75 different vitamins
minerals whole food sourced superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens
it's like the craziest healthiest thing
and i swear by it i use it every day it
improves my gut health it improves my
cognitive health really helps my brain
it gives me greens that honestly i'm not
eating so it's saving my butt and this
company's got a great deal for you if
you go to athleticgreens.com
stevo they're gonna send you
five of these travel packs
comprehensive convenient daily nutrition
times five plus a year's supply of
vitamin d which boosts your overall
immunity and you get that with your
first order if you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo i swear by it and you're gonna be
a much healthier person if you swear by
it too so
get on over to athleticgreens.com
stevo and now let's talk about detoxing
okay like i've i've detoxed at my at my
worst was probably november of 2020 um i
actually was smoking uh perc 30s um real
perk dirty still not fentanyl and i was
taking
20 fake exams a day that i later found
out were laced with heroin in it and i
remember uh looking in the mirror one
day and just being like if i keep doing
this i'm gonna die like i could already
start seeing like my cheekbones going
and stuff
and um i'm sorry what was the the
question because like when you're
detoxing off opiates you're kind of like
flu-like symptoms you're sick you're
nauseous yeah it's like xanax is like
okay oh yeah uh i would much rather
withdraw off opiates than xanax because
um uh the two drugs that you can
actually die from withdrawals from are
alcohol and xanax because you can have
seizures
oh and you started having seizures right
you were talking about that oh no last
time i had a seizure was uh november of
2020. i haven't had uh any okay and was
that seizure from quitting uh going cold
turkey off of xanax right opiate
opiates like you can lock someone in a
room for like 10 days they're going to
go through hell but they're not going to
die right you know what i mean i mean
necessarily i have hunger or something
like that yeah
yeah so i went in for about 20 narcos a
day and and 20 roseanne's no fentanyl in
my system
and it was a smooth process uh it went
well it was a nice facility i i did i
attended therapy and yoga and what what
brought about the
decision to go in there was it like
there was an intervention on you it
actually came uh from just me wanting to
change uh i cuz um
i felt like you know i'm 25 now and i i
just couldn't do it anymore because i
don't want to be because when you go
into those rehab centers there's people
in their 50s that i've been there
hundreds of times and they owe it and
i've been to seven you know in the last
like year
and um
they always tell me the same thing you
don't want to be this age in here you
want to nip it in the butt when
i got sober when i was 33. you know some
something like that yeah
yeah so this time i i know
i'm i'm so strong-headed i know i have
it this time
i would have loved to have gotten it
sooner than 33
and um
strong
headed
be careful with that yeah because like
what it is is is uh
surrendered you know like being no you
have to you have to be selfish uh
completely selfish to yourself and
surrender to the program right right
that my dad is actually the one that
told me surrender to the program because
he was addicted to meth uh for three
years like five years ago he's been
sober ever since
so uh he relates a little bit and he
told me this time you just gotta
surrender completely to the program and
i did this time and i it it helped out
tremendously i feel i feel really good
good i'm way past the withdrawals
um my skin is finally getting healthier
looking you know like good man yeah and
uh
so
you're going on tour again soon you said
20th the 28th actually yeah 28 and the
last tour you did sold out in five
minutes
have you put you posted this tour uh
this tour it's almost sold out almost
like we're doing uh that that tour was
uh a bigger tour like a thousand
twelve hundred people we're doing more
uh uh because this is the first tour
since the pandemic we're doing that like
300 capacity shows and they're almost
all sold out at this moment yeah so i'm
very blessed to sell the fandom because
i took a lot of time
uh off social media and away from the
fans to focus on my sobriety more
importantly time out of the studio yes i
took a lot yeah i have a lot of music uh
very good music too saved up like i i
have my album finished um
itself titled diego because this is
going to be the last project i dropped
under the name lil xan it's gonna be
little san diego then after that spotify
youtube channel everything's just gonna
be diego and i'm just gonna be an artist
as diego there you go because i want to
leave lil xan in the past and just be
diego and be an advocate for addiction
and was that that was a decision made in
sobriety like i don't want to be into
this yeah in during the the multiple
rehab since uh that was yeah that's cool
yeah thank you
yeah like would you have kids coming up
to you like man like i take so much
xanax 2 and you're like like yeah i have
that too but i also have a lot of people
saying that i've helped them out a lot
in my instagram dms and and they come up
to me uh and say the same thing and and
that that makes like my [ __ ] gear
because that's all i've ever wanted to
do in this world was help people like uh
not not trying to sound like a [ __ ]
saint but um even if
he wanted to help people and he wanted
to [ __ ] hoes [ __ ] hoes yeah
yeah i i definitely have done a lot of
that bro across like i've had sex with
so many women that don't even speak
english
and no that sounds pretty bad but i'm
talking about like europe and stuff
right um
and uh
you're kind of uh a legend in the
threesome department is that right yes
what's the secret to pulling a threesome
like just a threesome or
with your girl like having there's two
types you know it's like walk us through
it okay yeah
we're gonna need the whole menu
just for a regular threesome
uh i remember i was in london
and uh
my my dj was uh invited two girls over
and he was gonna sleep with both of them
but he was uh occupied doing something
else so i came in the room and where was
like
he wasn't in the room he was like it's
gotta be pretty important to pass up two
chicks yeah the guy probably just
stepped out to make a phone call and
little zan souped in
i didn't know the chicks were in there
to be honest so uh he's like down the
street grabbing food and they're like oh
where's john coming and i'm like oh i
don't know but you guys can chill in
here and
i don't know you just it i just
love language we just started
talking about it touching each other and
then i had sex with the two girls that
he was supposed to have sex with that's
a bad example maybe a bad friend move
definitely a bad friend i'm sorry john
um
but to a normal threesome
when you're on a tour bus and you you
know after a show they all come to your
tour bus you know to get autographs or
you know pictures and i do that i love
doing that i love i'll never deny a fan
a picture or an autograph anybody that
supports me i support them um but you
know you get this it's the groupies the
groupies and there's usually a part of a
tour bus and you probably notice too
that has like a back that slides back
the door it's like a little thing and
that's where all the business would go
down and like the three girls giving you
head at once for the most i ever did was
in new zealand i had a and then
every girl in this uh sick
well it was five girls plus me what is
that that's uh six sometimes six
and they were very beautiful new zealand
girls and it that was the the most
amazing moment of my life
six girls sucking your dick and having
sex and because they were all
participating with each other too they
were bi so it was like it was like a
rotation like coming in
switching over and you know
it's like the sushi joint that has the
carousel
yeah
but i was very proud i i i think i went
afterwards into the bathroom and uh
looked in the mirror and was like uh
your life begins today like yeah yeah
how many times have you thought back and
jerked off to that moment
um probably a couple times for sure
probably a couple times yeah but i i i
cherish that moment more as just
wow because i'm i i got no hoes in high
school like um you know i dropped i i
did drop out in ninth grade but like i
didn't even go to high school
yeah i didn't i didn't have enough time
maybe in that week
no no yeah i didn't get enough hoes in
middle school no um you went to high
school for seven days seven days uh
yeah but like but i had a lot of friends
in with high school and so i still stay
in touch with i had like a couple of
ugly girlfriends they were good people
though good personalities but i wasn't
getting girls you know like i wasn't
popular or i was a nerd i played video
games
i thought it was going to be like a
professional video game play
um so
help us understand what happened with
the this famous g wagon the famous g
wagon did you ever get it back
uh
yeah well actually this is some recent
stuff too
i did not
this is for the record i did not sell my
uh g-wagon for opiates i never would
have done that i used to have a
chauffeur and but he was a good friend
of mine named curly and he would drive
me places if he needed places to uh he
was from my hometown so sometimes he'd
have to drive it back to go see his
parents i'd let him use it and stuff
and um what happened was
uh stats it needed uh maintenance
because those g wagons are always in the
shop you know what i mean it's i would
never get a g wagon again so stat said
yo i'm gonna take it in and
my former manager stack quote so he
tricked curly and said y'all i'm gonna
pay for the maintenance fixes
and he came and took the car and just
never gave it back and they spun the
narrative as if i sold it for opiates
but what it what the g wagon is now is
we we came to an agreement just to sell
it and split split it uh 50 50. yeah
yeah but i i didn't sell it for open
but if i understood correctly you had
put
like all all the money and i got [ __ ]
over i got [ __ ] over yeah i got [ __ ]
over but i i'm debating whether to take
it to court or just let it slide
um because i did put 120 000 and it was
140 and i was making 800 payments so i
did get [ __ ] over but i i'm just i
think this is one where i'm just gonna
let it lift you know what i mean that i
mean
that i can see the logic in that i mean
is it hard to keep people around you to
trust or do you have a crew of people or
yeah i have the the best like those
people out there like are the best
people i have probably like five people
five friends and my and my girlfriend
that's it uh other than that just
acquaintances
and business partners i guess we had
t-pain on the podcast and he was talking
about how he had made like 40 million
dollars and then just blown through it
and got to a point where he could not
afford a whopper at burger king
and uh
and then he came and then he came back
you know like i wonder i don't know what
the particulars are of your financial
situation but
it sounded like all of that talk around
the g wagon was like
the the remainder of the thirty thousand
dollars needed to pay it off then it
just wasn't there yeah and so it's like
it kind of gave me the impression that
you had been like on fire just making
money like crazy and then all of a
sudden like just slow down and that went
away like pretty quick yeah well
like uh and i'm very open and talk um
talking about my financial situation
right now
no i'm not broke you know what i mean i
support my dad i support my mom i
brought my mom a house in temecula uh
paid full in cash i bought my data house
in uh corona very close to each other um
i did that um
there was a video where you did say that
you were broke
really oh no no that video was satire
because i was at uh
the the guy who created the app wish
uh peter he's a good friend of me he's
like a billionaire and that that was
just i i can't believe people didn't
pick that that was satire because i'm
walking through a mansion like while i'm
doing it and then showing like the
venador and then the golf course but i
think the clip that we saw it's it was
like you were like oh whatever brand
deal take it you know let's do the break
there's a day in the life of the no
jumper podcast yeah
take the brand or whatever whatever the
brain well if it was during the no
jumper time i definitely wasn't broke
then
and uh yo i mean wait maybe whatever i
mean i think broke is is a subject
suggestion yeah yeah okay i'll say this
from when from 2018 when i signed my
deal i'm nowhere near that rich uh as of
now but i am very
not like i'm far from broke so you're
dude you're comfortable i'm comfortable
and
you know having had that conversation
with t pain
and then kind of looking at what at what
your story
has seemed like over the last couple of
years i just feel like
if you're now in the position where
you're going back on tour and you're
selling tickets well it's like you kind
of have a rebirth yeah and so now
like
i
i want to think that you're going to
take uh have a different attitude about
the money that you earn and and how you
manage your opportunity and i totally
agree with that and and the first step
with that uh for you know um being more
uh fiscally responsible with my money
was getting clean to have a clear mind
clarity equal is gonna
make me lots of money because this tour
i'm netting is gonna i'm gonna bring
back 100k
i uh you know have a decent amount uh in
my bank account right now enough to
still support my parents with the
groceries and stuff uh enough to have a
nice uh you know little condo in l.a
um
and yeah and i i knew i needed to get
sober before i could start
be adulting because i feel like me
becoming an adult was stunted because i
had when i first got famous at 21 i was
still a kid and i was already addicted
coming into this stuff you know so and
but and at that point when i blew up i
had assistance around me doing
everything for me right like so it was
hard like you know to so now since 24
i've been and now like 25 i'm learning
how to do everything on my own because
it was stunning because i had someone to
do that for me somebody did that for
right but now that i'm sober
um thank god uh and have a clear sense a
clear sense of mind everything has been
going [ __ ] wonderful i'm on
antidepressants affects her they work
wonderful for me
um and yeah everything is just going so
great my girlfriend is a wonderful uh my
friends are wonderful and they're very
supportive none of them do drugs they
smoke a little weed and uh
and drink occasionally but man when when
i just met your dad outside yeah my way
to say that's
if you told me my dad's the coolest guy
man dude he's like my age yeah exactly
he's a 50. he just turned 50. holy [ __ ]
he looks like he's 35. my mom looks
young too that's why i look 16.
yeah that's really really insane that
that your dad's older than i am because
he yeah i was looking at your dad and i
was like dude no that's nice i told my i
tell my dad this every year i'm like bro
you're getting younger you have like the
benjamin button like yeah you have good
genes yeah and my dad also is a big
reason i became a musician because when
we were younger we he had a an extension
vinyl collection we'd listen to
everything from sid vicious to beethoven
to blur to gorillas you know so he got
me
uh to appreciate music to how i did i
nev i wanted to be a photographer and
document the underground la scene but
just from that background of loving
music so much and it being so important
to me
i think it helped be helped me become an
artist you know and because i appreciate
cinematography and music the most what
was a day in the life like of you like a
week before you blew up to like
celebrity a week before what were you
doing on a date i was sleeping at my
manager's studio it was like a warehouse
it was nice it was a nice studio like a
nice i was sleeping on the couch but
you're broke but i i was essentially
broke i mean
there's no money sleeping maybe a
hundred dollars in in my pocket not even
a bank account
um driving a nissan versa you know what
i mean that's a great cars man i had one
of those steve had one of those after he
made all of his money yeah i might get
enough that was the first car steve
bought after he made money i might i
might sue bubba when you saw first
nowadays but um um yeah and then we uh
we link with the good cole bennett of
lyrical lemonade he's a good friend of
mine um we have six videos and
um but he did my first one betrayed
that was the one that was and now
thank you i appreciate that and that was
the one
and uh that blew me up so
after that that broke week the i did
that song came out on lyrical lemonade
and then the next day it has 10 million
views and i have never had 10 million
anything so i'm like looking at this
like who's who's [ __ ] with me who
like you know what i mean i'm like like
because i was making music like as a
hobby almost at this point
um but it was real and you had the full
face tats at that time i had like five
i've gone overboard at this point but i
had five
it's a little much
better
and then after that watching my
instagram go up like to 70 000 followers
in
two hours and then it was at a hundred
thousand
the next day damn and then three days
later 300 000 and then um two months
later 1.2 million and i'm at columbia
signing a deal
it was it was so fast heavy and then
reserve oh go ahead where are you at in
the columbia deal now uh i'm independent
me and columbia uh uh separated ways we
uh had uh
just uh did you finish out the contract
by delivering however many albums it was
no i didn't finish out the contract i i
didn't like the the creative control
they they didn't give me much creative
control
um they wanted to kind of turn me into
something else that i didn't want to be
so we agreed to part ways but
unfortunately in order to do that i had
to give them uh all my all my masters
so i don't make i don't make money off
my music but when now all your masters
that would be
the master like that would just be
betrayed uh color blind and slingshot
because betrayed was the first track on
your your first album yes yes so the the
basically the three biggest songs well
well i did a song when i was dating noah
cyrus called live or die
uh so they own four of my biggest songs
masters everything else i own
okay but it still sucks you know that
you know you don't own like betrayed or
colorblind
but then again i mean historically like
the music industry has been this
catch-22
of you can't blow up unless you have a
record deal but you can't make money
unless you
own your own [ __ ] yeah so you served the
purpose of blowing up now
theoretically you can put out your own
music own it and actually make the money
off yeah and that's what me and my new i
just got a new team um and that's what
we're doing now we're getting i got a
publicist now
i i'm so i have things now that i should
have had years and years ago you know
what i mean well you're only 25 so
no no but i mean like when i was with my
old team you know i understood yeah
like uh there was a lot of criticism
about that first album yet and i can
tell you why
if you want to improve your future you
gotta have an understanding of your past
is that fair to say
that's why
my whoop band is helping me so immensely
this is the most sophisticated fitness
tracking device known to man
and they just came out with the whoop
band 4.0 which comes with the waterproof
wireless charger and as always they've
got a great deal for the listeners of
the wild ride podcast now keep in mind
that with your whoop membership you've
got a stream coach which is going to
take all of the data that the band pulls
from you and it's going to tell you what
you need to do what you're focusing on
how you can be healthier it's going to
give you all the insights into your
sleep your recovery the calories you're
burning the activities you're doing it's
gonna get you organized to become a
healthier person and if you go to
woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p-dot
and use the promo code stevo you're
going to get 15
off your membership at checkout plus you
get this killer band with the waterproof
wireless charger totally for free i'm
telling you you want to join the
movement you want to support the wild
ride podcast and you want to be a
healthier happier person so go to
woop.com use the promo code stevo and
get on board all right
all right now let's see what happened
with that album
um it was very rushed
um
my manager stack quo which fun fact
about statquo he was uh the first artist
signed to shady aftermath with dr dre
and eminem
um so he has he was actually popping out
in like the early 2000s as a rapper but
that didn't work out for him so he went
behind the scenes and wanted to manage
artists and i was his first artist to
blow up
um
and uh [ __ ] i was just lost
yeah i mean it's okay like uh
i i felt like you were
saying you know why the album was
critical
yo it was rush what if we just said you
weren't sober you didn't put in the work
i wasn't sober uh
i didn't put in the work enough i mean
the color blind on it was good moonlight
on it was good uh basically all the
records that were already doing good
that were on the album
they were good songs on the album and
and a couple others but it was rushed um
and i was on drugs
and i feel like my team i'm not blaming
my team for this at all it's you know
but i feel like they should have
it you know lis because they're powerful
people in the industry i feel like they
should have listened to this and been
like we should not put this out okay
that i mean
that's fair sadly they did put it out
you did put it out it's your name on it
yeah um but you're [ __ ] blown up
because of it
well you were already you had blown up
already right you had blown up
when you signed the deal
what was your motivation to do that
because was it just a big sign
or something for uh what's your first
time with columbia signing because
because
my my uh previous manager stack quo
was uh he was friends with uh uh jimmy
iveen's um nephew and they they they're
like columbia family so they wanted me
to just be
that goal with them you know kind of
stuff yeah and i bring up the criticism
of that first album because like i think
that it's healthy to just acknowledge
like whatever the issue was
so that you can address it moving
forward because like you said you've got
you've got a bunch of music and it's
good music yeah because that album was
dropped in 2018 and and you know it's
been years and years since i've dropped
because i've refused to drop something
that's gonna turn out like that again
you know what i mean right that's what i
want to hear do i want your next album
to be like [ __ ] it's no
it's like bro it's like it's like it's
like a mixture of rap and indie it's
kind of like indie indie and rap it's
got a lot more instruments and
presumably you recorded it before you
just went into rehab uh i've been
recording um for the last seven months
for this album yeah like in between
rehabs and stuff but it's sounding
really good there's some like a lot more
instruments a lot more like uh like
violins and pop punk stuff and i got you
know the typical bangers
and but uh more topics more
more lyricism more but but but also
retaining the little xan style you know
are you putting it out on your own uh i
believe i'm going to put it out on my
own yes
so you don't make any money up front
when you put it on your own right
there's no royalties
like i said i'm living comfortably but
the most important thing for me for this
next thing is just to show people how
much i've evolved and that i'm ready i'm
ready to play ball like and to be taken
serious
you know because this next album in my
opinion is
i'm so proud of it i'm very proud of it
you know that's good
i could make nothing off it i just want
them to know
like let's go you know what i mean you
guys got any features on it uh it's just
going to be just strictly me i just
wanted it it's not too late to add
features though right because i think i
think my my friend p and b rock who's a
big rapper might hop on a couple things
and uh some low-key artists but for the
most part since it's self-titled my name
i kind of just want it to be you know
just mostly me
um and you know i started rapping again
is that what you're gonna say um
[Applause]
to do the intro dude i would love that
that'd be sick
and i gotta say too man that uh you know
for
for for all the stuff that that i've
seen
like uh
it's really refreshing how how candid
you are thank you and uh you know i like
i i think you're in a good spot dude
thank you yeah good place i appreciate
that because like
the thing with the internet and the
pandemic definitely like
fast forwarded the internet so much
because people had nothing to do it like
evolved it way quicker you know
uh there's such a false narrative of me
on the internet that i'm like a bar
[ __ ] [ __ ] like illiterate like a dick
[ __ ] like mean person but like i
always tell people
and i know it's not possible to meet
everybody in the world and have five
minutes to talk to him but if you would
just sit down and talk to me for five
minutes you would you would probably
like me because i'm genuinely a nice guy
and polite you know i don't want to
start any issues i just want to help
people and if you still hate me then not
your decision i can't change that but
you know just don't believe everything
you see on the internet because it's not
real
dude
i agree with that and and i i don't know
that i've seen anything suggesting that
you're not a nice guy i haven't heard
anything saying well there was the tupac
uh incident something that you said
tupac
yeah but that was back when i was barred
out and they would wake me up at 5 00
a.m and i was cranky uh to go to the
iheart radios you know and i rated and
and i don't feel this way anymore tupac
is a legend but i i wanted to get the
interview over with the interviewer was
annoying and she just kept speeding this
and she's like what do you feel about
tupac and i was like two out of ten and
that was like such a big catalyst of
hate you know what i mean yeah but at
the same time so i don't have to like
i was barred out i was cr like cranky
you know everybody just got your dick
sucked by six chicks sick [ __ ]
[ __ ] 10 chicks yeah you're just
thinking about your nose
who knows what i got my dick somebody uh
no but you know like um
yeah but no tupac is definitely a legend
and i i i would like to stop receiving
uh death threats for that yeah do you
have a uh i i don't know why i asked
this question but it's so fascinating
like if you have a top five uh best
rappers of all time in your opinion
well okay yeah um in order from like um
five to one five the one the one being
the best yeah yeah okay five i would
have to say xxx centasyon he was a good
friend of mine
um for little peep um i i didn't know
him but his his music was amazing
uh three juice world rest in peace the
m2 we all came kind of up from the sound
clutter
wow all three guys his name have passed
it's sad right uh three of uh so one two
two rounded two two i would say king von
rest in peace again
um
and one who actually was a good friend
of mine mac miller
[ __ ] oh
and it's all five what did they all die
of
uh drug overdoses and gunshots yeah
gunshots and mack was the drug overdose
but as a story about mac was um
i started listening to mac in 2009 when
i was like 12 or something you know
and um and i fell in love with his music
and
i fell in love with how every album it
was a different mac it was a it like his
whole discography from the beginning to
the end is and he's just watching the
evolution was amazing so he became my
favorite artist throughout the years of
me
dropping out of high school bumping into
music and then my music brought us
together later in life which blew my
mind because that was my idol you know
what i mean and then he invited me to
actually what would be his last show at
the hotel cafe in uh
in downtown
and um i got to see him perform 100
people it was like you had to win like a
radio giveaway to go there very intimate
i met his family i met jason sedegas
when he was with olivia wilde back there
john mayer
and uh and mack was like yo uh next week
let's uh
or like next month let's uh uh come over
and let's jam out and i was like wow i'm
gonna make a song with my idol that's
crazy you know so i left i said it was a
good show
and then i was born september 6th
uh he died september 7th
and so we never got to do that and then
after that after mack miller passed that
that would that hurt me the most someone
yeah and you decided that you were going
to not make music
yo if if uh if my producer is here he'd
make fun of that uh comment right now so
much he says why do you retire every
month like you know what i mean i i i do
it as a joke you know what i mean but at
the at the time with the math thing when
i was crying on live i probably did feel
like i wanted to retire but now i just
do it as a [ __ ] joke like i'm like oh
i retired until i come back you know
right i just think like whenever
somebody loses a loved one you know it
it's it's sad
you should grieve
i i urge people to grieve selfishly
you know and then get it get over it and
move on and and let your motivation be
to honor
the the memory of your loved one
by
being happy and healthy
like that like your loved one would want
you to be yeah like if i were to ask you
what do you think mac miller would want
for you well he would be like [ __ ]
dude get out there and make me his last
words would uh to me were be safe
all right and he mac would want you to
make music if matt heard that you were
gonna not make music because he died
that that's not that's not honoring i
think yeah i think it was just because
it was a day after my birthday and it
was just in the moment you know but i'm
i'm not retired at all you know my my
next album is on my birthday september
6th
um
and it's called diego yeah that's when
it's dropping yeah september september
6th yeah so you got all the artwork done
yeah yeah the artwork is on my instagram
and then it's all mastered at the time
we still have to master a few of them
and when you know we got time to go in
and maybe change and [ __ ] with it you
know what does mastered mean matt it's
it's it's like uh if you're in
a video project like doing the color
correction like it's like the finishing
the polishing there's like fishing dudes
engineer like who will record you the
engineer records you make you sound as
good as he can doing there but then you
send it off to someone like john bryan a
great
master to like
make like make it sound full in the car
like so when they say you got your
masters that means you have the final
but like does that mean you have the
before project before you send it to the
master no that's a different type of
math yeah masters and master that that
master the noun has been mastered and
such locked yeah
[Music]
yeah i love it yeah in the mastering
engineer they'll make it sure it's like
all the same volume so if you're
flipping through spotify it's not like
one song is quiet one song
quality test for cars earphones and make
sure it sounds good in every spot if you
ever hear a song if you turn it up
really loud like the vocals like it
sounds bad
every device it's going to be listened
to
it's going to sound like a photo like
the photographer would be like oh let me
edit the photo yeah
kind of but that's like the mixer
because like someone will mix it too you
know like the recording engineer will
record it then the mixing guy would be
like okay the trumpets need to be louder
here the guitar yeah then they send just
like a stereo file to the mastering guy
and the mastering guy will just hear the
stereo file and just give it a little
more bass or a little more volume or
whatever it is okay i got a couple
questions
like uh
you're such an easy going laid back nice
guy thank you but have you had any like
really intense rap beefs like feuds
feuds uh i think back in 2018 when i was
again off my [ __ ] um
i feuded with this canadian rapper named
kelly
and uh
we just you know went back and forth
through various social media outlets
uh and then um i had a show in his town
and he actually ran up on me
uh but uh my security
like defused the situation but other
than that
no i mean for everything is cool with
him now yeah or no he we he he he
probably still hates me but like i'm i'm
trying to go on this whole peace vibe
thing i have nothing against anybody he
probably still hates me kelly i have
nothing against you it was a different
time i was a different person
um and other than that um kelly he was
just a kid
yeah but other than that wokka flock and
t.i were coming at me on twitter after
the tupac stuff and uh
but you know it's all love i have
nothing against anybody um i'm trying to
really excuse me
um trying to change for the better you
know i have this descent i love the word
clarity i really do love the word
clarity you know um and that's what i
feel like i have right now and that's
why i feel like i'm doing so much better
good good
um
man
i have a question so so the albums when
the album's finished
it's launching september 6th yes
when the night before september
september 5th and okay we're going to
blast it out at midnight oh well
is it available for pre-order already oh
not yet but and then in a week it will
be though so so then okay let's
do you gather up all the pre-orders or
when you hit play
it goes to spotify apple makes records
it like where does it go as soon as you
hit play
is that like the release date how can
people cop it like uh are people still
buying albums you usually put a link
tree in your bio that will direct it if
you want to listen to it on from the
youtube or spotify or apple music you
make that link tree and in your bio so
you click that and if they would have
spotify they'll click the spotify one so
when you launch it you drive all the
traffic to your page and then they go
wherever they want from there and we
promote it on my page like you know
so much you know just driving the
traffic through
get big uh
you know pay a spotify playlist to get
it on new music friday the hottest
playlist uh get it on big like at rap
and double xl to post like exam drops
and music you know do you um
do you have a date the the pre-order
will go live um i do not yet
unfortunately you know we're still
working on that what's a good number for
a pre-order album like to buy like when
you're like oh [ __ ]
like is it gold platinum like what are
those hundred thousand
if you sold 100 000 is that good yeah oh
it's not going to sell 100 000 units
because i've been away for so long i
would be happy if it sold 30 000 to be
honest because of how much time i've
taken away from social media to work on
myself and stuff i mean you tweeted out
to come to redlands in 20 minutes you
had two thousand people yeah i did i yo
and you might be right i might do that
again i always doubt myself i feel like
that's the virgo artist in me you know
we always doubt ourselves but what would
you be happy with i would i wouldn't be
happy with 30 000 30 you'd be like [ __ ]
yeah but the internet trolls would be
like ll
it's like well you guys don't understand
i haven't dropped anything in four years
i've been absent from social media
thirty thousand would be amazing for me
but you're not saying thirty seven
thousand
streams yeah
and on top of that like i said again
it's not even for the money for me it's
for just to show them and yeah you know
and evolved zan or diego yeah it's crazy
like music videos you're it's like oh
that music video is six it's sick and
you look at it on youtube it's got like
800 million views it's like
people love [ __ ] music they love
music videos yeah bro music uh
there's i mean maybe this is biased
because i know some people that don't
actually listen to music or they just
listen to top 40 you know but uh music
is my life you know i think music is it
brings people together
um
it's it's i think it's the best thing in
the world what are you jamming these
days like what are you playing in the
car uh well it depends on the vibe you
know if i'm cruising down the street
maybe some day lost soul tribe called
quest uh
i like um i like young thug a lot mac
miller of course
um there's this new artist yeet uh you
know about yeah yeah why haven't i heard
that yeah yeah
yeah he's he's funny man uh trippy red
chubby red's really good uh kg elephant
the strokes uh arctic monkeys i grew up
on arctic monkeys uh belly and sebastian
love billy and sebastian but if you if
you were on an island and you could only
take one album what would it be
uh oh my god that's all tupac always i
mean
i also like drake a lot too and kanye
but if i was what was the question if
you're like or if you know going to
rehab or if you had to go to an island
you can only take one album with you
what album would that be it would
probably be the divine feminine by mac
miller
yes definitely
all right steve what about you
man i was just thinking
uh about that i think i'd do like a
grateful dead album
i don't know man
wait wait wait oh wait okay that album
and if but if i could take two it would
be uh what people uh whatever people say
i am that's what i'm not that's arctic
monkey's first album when they were
really punk rock it'd be one of those 12
one that i've just been my latest thing
is uh just pulling up albums on uh
apple music
which i just haven't listened to in a
long time and i've been particularly
enjoying a perfect circle merida noms
hmm
nice very cool i'm going to check that
out
yeah it's uh
yeah it like it and it's more about like
time traveling to just this like
this
period of my life where like whoa you
know yeah because that's really what
music is music is uh
something that you escape quality well
it's like an album is is like a blank
canvas and as you listen to it you
record on to that canvas
that period of your life so then years
later if you hear that music again it
takes you back to that period yeah
your moment in your life with this
this soundtrack i like that i've never
heard that expression before but i
actually really do like that yeah and
people ask me like what uh
kind of music i like you know and again
i've always said that
um
i i feel that music is is not as much to
be liked as it is to become familiar
with because as you become familiar with
it you fuse
your own experience with it and so you
have that that identification with it
and so it's less about how much you like
the music and it's more about how
how
intimately
attached to the music you are so
experience of music is more about just
your familiarity with it i like that i i
feel like i relate to that on the the
gorillas of the gorillas album with
demon days yep like and the song demon
days and the one that lee i forgot what
the first one but it leads into demon
days like you just
it means something different to
everybody you know like you
i don't know you described it better
than me bro i i i i know what you mean
but yeah the other thing too i was like
to say is that music i feel is like food
you know you don't always want to eat
[ __ ] donuts you know like sometimes
you're in the mood for
sweet food sometimes you're in the mood
for chips and salsa like sometimes you
want to [ __ ] yeah like you want to
change it you want to change it up yeah
like sometimes you want donuts sometimes
you want butterfield yeah
sometimes i catch myself just keep
listening to the same 10 songs over and
over again
my highest goal in life as it relates to
music is to commit myself to listen to
one album and nothing but one album on
repeat over and over and over for weeks
on end so that i've invested this
portion of my life in that music and
then when i hear it years on down the
road it'll take me back yeah i wanna i
wanna like fuse
where i'm at and i just don't do enough
because i keep living in the past by my
time traveling to previous points of
mine yeah like yeah there's always a
feeling i like that man i'm resistant to
new music and i wish i wasn't so
resistant but every once in a while like
i asked someone hey what's up a great
album
from start to finish so i can just
listen to nothing but that yeah i did
that with your strokes album [ __ ] yeah
is this it
the first one must have been is this it
oh is it that i think that would be what
i would take
i did it again with the yeah yeah yeah
everybody yeah
yeah yeah when i was like this is like
you're going to love this album but then
you're like played again it was like
this is like five times really good
album though it's so good and you did
that with maggot brain i think too funky
jonestown max massacre
johnson yeah
all jay we did that a lot dude yeah big
time started to silly with bam's album
yeah bam's album was just dad bam put
out this album the eavesdroppers [ __ ]
epic well i walked into we was on tour
in europe and i like walked upstairs i'm
like dude who is this this is sick i
have a crazy story with bam actually jay
let's hear it
so i'm from redlands california and um
one day i'm just sitting at my house and
i get a
text message because uh i guess bam's
photographer is a mutual friend of mine
or something
ryan g uh
some
illegals illegal vehicle some i don't
know what it was but uh
he texted me he said yo bam once and uh
once the job i gave him and i was like
yeah of course bam and he hits me up and
he's like yo um because i'm from
brethren california he's like i'm doing
something at redlands skatepark for like
their grand opening or something oh this
was for like he made a music video or
something no no no this is something
else that was the when the dude fell
through the [ __ ] thing yeah that was
funny um so
he was like i'm gonna hit him up because
i know he zan's from redlands you know
so i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm stoked so we
sent a a chauffeur to come get me and my
friends but he had a request he said can
you bring a gun because i've never shot
a gun before
and i was like bama or jerry asked me
for a gun
i got to get a gun like let's go get a
gun let's make this epic you know let's
go to the back wash because there's like
you know washes back there where
nobody's gonna hear it and stuff so
are you a gun guy have you yeah yeah i i
i i like going to ranges and stuff and
it was a legal gun obviously obviously
it was illegal but um serial numbers
were scratched yeah yeah
bullet yeah
hollow points no but uh so we went we
ended up going
and um
uh he did like a little interview with
me it was kind of awkward i didn't know
it was really going on this wasn't
terribly long ago right like yeah this
was this was about a yeah exactly a year
ago you know
at the time uh or maybe yeah it made
clip made like a year and a half yeah
yeah it could yeah it could have been
like longer um
and uh so we did the skatepark thing you
know it was uh they were having an event
and people were kind of taking pictures
of him me it was cool and then danny
wade was there too danny wade was one
that brought him and i'm a big you know
i uh i i grew up skateboarding i was
never good but i still enjoyed the
culture and danny way jumped the great
wall of china like so you know and
that's who took bam the redlands so i
showed up we all met i got to meet uh
danny way legend got to meet bam you
know legend too it was sick um
and then we had the guns like well let's
go shoot the gun i'm like jesus i'm
really about i'm in my hometown with
bamar jaren danny [ __ ] way and i
brought them a gun
and robotical shoot it off
and
in the fields like far away from
anywhere where it would be bad but bam
was telling me he had never shot a gun
before and that's why he wanted to do it
and i was like damn how in the [ __ ] is
there any way you've never shot a gun
before you crazy ass [ __ ] you
know what i mean but i guess he hadn't
because he was shaking when he held that
gun uh i'll show you videos after this
too i have it
um and yeah we went to the the little
backwash and and shot guns uh for a
little while danny wade went crazy on it
what kind of gun was it oh it was just a
glock nine millimeter um and yeah and
after that uh we just parted ways and
that was my bam experience
cool didn't he like shoot the car or
something
uh we were shooting at like bottles in
the back because uh we didn't want to
shoot up rocks and ricochet and die why
did you post did he post on a story one
time he got in that car he got his car
stolen that's what it was oh yeah he was
telling me about that that was that this
was also right after his bentley was
stolen and crashed
yeah so that he was telling me about
that stuff too
yeah yeah it's a pretty gnarly situation
man
yeah i i'm i'm slightly familiar with it
um but i'm not you know obviously too
familiar with the whole situation yeah i
see him working out on like novak's
instagram right and yeah he told me a
lot of crazy stories about novak too but
um
like like i'm not trying to like talk
[ __ ] on bam because like all of you guys
are legends you know jackass is amazing
you know jeff jermaine and spike jones
all you know amazing people but um he
just didn't seem like himself he kind of
just well right i mean at that time he
wasn't himself
there's nothing about uh he was still
getting a lot of love from everybody
he's a likable guy i mean people like
him they always will
yeah and anything negative like and this
kid is amazing yeah yeah yeah you're not
talking [ __ ] to say that that's yeah and
everybody wants bam to be
in the best place and yeah happy and
healthy and yeah i saw the movie too it
was amazing
i thought you guys were gonna like uh
go a little less hard since y'all were
getting a little bit older you know but
when i saw johnny knoxville get [ __ ]
by that bull i was like these guys are
crazy
yeah
it was it was is there like are you guys
planning on like a jackass next
generation kind of thing i mean i guess
that's kind of what this this uh last
movie because i know zack ass and i know
chad tepper oh yeah they uh i mean yeah
they brought in zach they brought in
poopy they brought in a bunch of new
guys to kind of uh freshen it up a
little bit yeah you know i don't know
why celebrities mgk i saw that yeah i
don't know but i always felt i always
felt like there should be like a jackass
next generation because like jackass
can't just end it never will and like i
mean
i don't know i mean unless that's what
you guys have decided on but i'll tell
you this when i found out that after 10
years knoxville wanted to make another
movie like i thought
man like
after every that now we're so old that's
a
potential problem
and like after everything that we've
survived like we've come this far and
like now like it just takes one [ __ ]
thing to go wrong and then the whole
legacy of it
so when you say like the jackass the
next generation
you got younger kids i just worry about
like taking risks on and it's
ironic that i should be saying that you
know but uh no but it's it's respectable
because i do see where we're yeah
you know and and i mean the the
particularly ironic thing is that i'll
be taking plenty more risks just you
know doing my own thing
but uh you're putting out your own album
yeah putting on my own album and you
know like
such a weird thing with jackass when uh
you know like putting putting other
people in harm's way
yes
i mean some of the stuff you have coming
up is
some of the gnarliest i've ever heard in
my entire life so that'll be interesting
i'm excited to see that
yeah when you swallowed that goal of
[ __ ]
that was a long long time ago man it was
day one so uh okay so how can we help
you with uh you know
sending what traffic that we can send
for you we want to get to your your
instagram
followers listen on instagram like i do
definitely uh follow me uh at za anxiety
it's basically just uh anxiety with an x
in front of it anxiety with an x in
front of its anxiety uh follow me there
uh uh i don't really use anything else
besides that so that's yeah that's
probably the only place and uh
presumably um
this will come out about the same time
as pre-order so look up
lil xan's new album it's called diego
yeah go self-titled diego and this is
the last project dropping under the name
uh lil xand and everything changes to
diego uh i'll let all my social media uh
platforms know when the pre-orders go on
and everything because like projects
really uh
gain momentum on healthy pre-orders so
yeah no it is pre-orders really help a
lot really important like shoot it to
the top man right because that because
when it goes on sale
like that first week it gets all the
pre-orders are credited to that first
week exactly so that that determines
it's the same with books that's why i
want everybody to approve and everybody
is just so pressed about how many albums
like how many units you sell it's like
bros
chill out bro like yeah
um and uh like where are you at with the
with the sobriety like
you're okay with the yeah the weed
you're gonna keep doing the weird thing
uh occasionally like i might smoke a
joint today but that'll probably
probably won't smoke another one for
like three days you know um just you
know celebrate and stuff uh yeah but
scott and i are sober guys both of us
and i think i can speak for both of us
when i say
if that works for you yeah our hats are
off to you yeah because let me tell you
i do believe weed is a gateway drill i
100 believe weed is a gateway drug but
um yeah like whatever works for certain
people when i was at the heavenly center
i applaud them for trying something
different but it wasn't for me i didn't
smoke weed during the process and they
were okay with that they don't shove it
down your throats you know what i mean
and they really did help me so shout out
steve labelle shout out nick shout out
matt um scott scott scott storch amazing
producer
um they really yeah and uh today i just
posted on instagram earlier uh it's my
40th day sober all right that's super
cool yeah and i know how hard that is so
and you've made it past the hard part
yeah yeah yeah keep it there yeah yeah
man the first like three weeks are like
really hard man
yeah and um if the weed and the
marijuana maintenance as we call it if
that works for you then that's great if
it doesn't work for you then i would
just recognize that sooner than later
you don't want to just go around the
same loop of like [ __ ] i got voted again
[ __ ] i've already this is my seventh
time in rehab and i'm trying to make it
my last i feel really good about it this
time and yeah and i want to thank you
guys for having me on you're an amazing
guest an amazing person thank you yeah
like
right away when we spoke yeah i got that
i know we
accidentally i was freaking out with my
wallet he's walking in the barn and i'm
like okay
for sure
by the way it looks like your wallet
showed up
i was like yo look up what stevo's
favorite snacks are it's like
butterfingers and reese's all right
let's give them some flour there that's
time to can you grab that right there
just so that anybody who is
uh actually on the youtubers guys i
swear to god i'm a nice person he's a
very nice no more dead
what a young gentleman
zan got me uh
butterfinger and reese's and a bunch of
flowers yes
can you even believe that oh dude we
need to stick that on me dude yeah let's
take the stick down
yeah
yo
maybe this is for the thumbnail
you want to hold this
[Music]
all right so for people just listening
we're getting a little photo shoot here
steve's got uh the little zen
beanie on we got the flowers in the
middle we got wendy
you should go to youtube for that shot
yeah
but yeah man dude i'm rooting for you
bro yeah thank you so much man i
appreciate you guys i'm rooting for you
i want this next album to bring you back
to the full splendor of your uh it's
going to be splendid in 2018. yeah and i
really want you to stay sober you know i
promise yeah i got this i can't promise
dude that's the definition of uh
addiction is that okay
yeah you know okay well i i will remain
sober okay today
he's like where do i put this [ __ ] out
it's all good you want to air drop it
you want to text the tv
now tell me how can you not be rooting
for that kid after listening to that
podcast i mean
what a likable dude i'm rooting for him
man like i said i hope that this next
album he puts out is an absolute banger
i hope it smashes
ah
i mean
and you know what
i've said it before and i'll say it
again i appreciate the [ __ ] out of you
guys who stick around to the end of the
podcast i've said this before as well
that more and more when i'm on tour
meeting people at my shows
people are telling me yo dude i'm street
team and i love that so let's go full
street team on this one and
give lil xan some love he's like since
we uh recorded this he's posted about it
on his instagram like
five times or something and it's not
even out yet so
he's stoked that he's on the wild ride
podcast now i'd love it if you let him
that you're stoked too let him know
uh so yeah grab a screenshot post it up
tag lilzand give him some love and let's
all root for this kid to really have a
redemption
thank you and lots of love